[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
noch ist annalena baerbock neu auf der
internationalen bühne die deutsche
außenministerin absolvierte im dezember
antritt besucher von denen es vor allem
galt keine fehler zu machen und nicht in
fettnäpfchen zu treten doch jetzt wird
es ernst mitten in der sich zuspitzenden
krise an der ukrainischen grenze ist per
box vermittlungs geschick gefragt ihrem
antrittsbesuch heute in kiel folgt
morgen der in moskau wo sie es mit dem
russischen amtskollegen lavive zu tun
bekommt neu auf der bühne zu sein ist
das vorteil oder nachteil
bamberg setzte heute in kiew ganz auf
diplomatie andreas künast hat sie
begleitet
wenn die außenministerin etwas sagen
will hat sie die wahl das wort oder das
bild annalena baerbock beginnt den tag
schweigend aber ihre botschaft ist gut
zu verstehen zehn rote rosen am denkmal
der himmlischen 100 wie die menschen in
kiew die 100 väter söhne töchter nennen
die auf dem majdan ihr leben verloren
2014 als sich die ukraine für den weg
nach westen entschied für den sie bis
heute besetzt beschränkt bedroht wird
das bild ist per box erstes wort in der
ukraine
die deutsche außenministerin kommt in
ein aufgewühltes land vor dessen grenze
hundert tausend russische soldaten
stehen berbalk sagt außenminister
cholera zu sich morgen in moskau mit
allen diplomatischen mitteln für die
sicherheit der ukraine einzusetzen
hinter uns liegt eine woche erste
gespräche mit russland mit einem
durchbruch innerhalb von wenigen stunden
haben wir nach jahren des schweigens
nicht gerechnet wir sehen dass es
offensichtlich dass wir an sehr sehr
vielen punkten meilenweit
auseinanderliegen die ukraine ist in
aufruhr heute der box besucht fällt mit
der rückkehr von ex präsident
poroschenko zusammen der die russland
politik seiner nachfolger gefährlich
nachgiebig findet und sich dafür von
seinen anhängern freudig durch schubsen
lässt poroschenko kommt aus polen und
wird vom aktuellen präsidenten des
hochverrats bezichtigt sie hier finden
es müsste andersrum sein
wenn präsident selensky unsere
interessen nicht schützt wie sollen wir
da von deutschland verlangen unsere
interessen zu schützen
die ukraine weiß was sie von deutschland
verlangen kann und was nicht so sehr sie
auch auf ihre geschichte verweist die
lieferung von verteidigungswaffen lehnt
die bundesregierung ab
wir wissen wofür wir waffen brauchen wir
brauchen sie ausschließlich für die
verteidigung unseres hoheitsgebiets
die haltung der deutschen
bundesregierung mit blick auf
waffenlieferungen und zwar mit blick auf
eine restriktive rüstungsexportpolitik
die ist ja nicht nur bekanntermaßen
bekannt sondern sie es auch in unserer
geschichte begründet präsident selensky
würde sich gern mit präsident putin
treffen unter beteiligung deutschlands
und frankreichs aber putin ist skeptisch
morgen will berbalk in moskau für dieses
gipfeltreffen werben es kommt auf bild
und wort an auf jedes
ja und wir wollen nachfragen bei andreas
kühner der uns vom mai dann in kiew
zugeschaltet ist andreas annalena
baerbock ukrainische forderung heute
gleich in mehreren punkten enttäuscht
inzwischen ist sie nach moskau
weitergereist wie zuversichtlich ist sie
denn selbst dass ihre vorschläge da
gehör finden
na ja also das ziel von bernburg ist
lässt sich herunterbrechen auf die
formel keine gespräche über die ukraine
ohne die ukraine und es soll eben nicht
mehr so sein wie in der vergangenen
woche dass die amerikaner und die russen
miteinander reden und die europäer und
da vor allem die ukraine
gezwungen sind aus der ferne zu sehen
berbalk will das einzige format
wiederbeleben in dem sich präsident
putin und präsident sie lenski bisher
die hand gegeben haben das ist das
sogenannte norma und die format also ein
gipfeltreffen zwischen dem ukrainischen
dem russischen dem französischen
präsidenten und dem deutschen kanzler
und sie will das gemeinsam mit
bundeskanzler scholz schaffen dass diese
vier an einen tisch kommen nun wird
russland sehr genau registriert haben
dass sich die grünen politikerin bärbel
im wahlkampf ja deutlich gegen nord
stream zwei die pipeline ausgesprochen
hat anders als der jetzige spd
bundeskanzler scholz da wird man sie
testen oder ob deutschland mit einer
stimme spricht
ja und das hat heute schon begonnen in
dem die ukrainischen journalisten aus
nord stream 2 und dem doch
unterschiedlichen einschätzungen in der
deutschen ampelkoalition ein großes
thema gemacht haben es ist so dass
berbalk diese differenzen so ein
bisschen versucht weg zu reden und das
gelingt auch ganz gut innerhalb der
regierung aber es gelingt nicht mehr gut
innerhalb der ampel parteien da ist
jetzt doch zwischen spd und grünen
ziemlich öffentlich auch der streit
entbrannt und das ist natürlich ein
zusätzlicher ballast auf der box weg
durch dieses doch schwieriger
diplomatische gelände morgen schwieriges
diplomatisches gelände dankeschön
andreas kienast nach kiew unter bleiben
viele fragen noch aus berlin
zugeschaltet begrüße ich jetzt wolfgang
ischinger exzellenter außenpolitischer
experte lange jahre deutscher diplomat
in verschiedenen wichtigen positionen
und noch der chef der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz schon genannt herr
ischinger globe der besuch der deutschen
außenministerin damit werden gerade auch
noch mal gehört durchaus ungeheuren
erwartungen fast verbunden was was
glauben sie kann sie tatsächlich
ausrichten morgen in moskau ich bin in
der tat der meinung dass man die
erwartungen an das was bei diesem besuch
erreicht werden kann er runterschrauben
sollte wir dürfen diesen das ist ja ein
antrittsbesuch der deutschen
außenministerin in einer
außerordentlich komplexen
internationalen gemengelagen also tiefer
hängen
das beste was aus meiner sicht
herauskommen könnte ich bin aber
skeptisch ob das überhaupt erreichbar
wäre ist eine wiederbelebung des gerade
ja schon erwähnten normandie formats
also von tatsächlichen gesprächen
verhandlungen über die lösung des
konflikts bildern was das essen viel
glauben sie daran denn die russen
russland will ja vor allem mit den usa
reden exakt so ist es und deswegen bin
ich persönlich dass meine persönliche
meinung der auffassung man müsste
eigentlich angesichts der jetzt
entstandene lage unsere amerikanischen
freunde bitten
diese verhandlungen vielleicht nicht zu
führen aber sich doch an ihnen direkt zu
beteiligen damit den russen jemandem
gegenübersitzt denn sie ernst nehmen
anna lena berger bekommt es bei sergej
lavrov mit einem außenpolitischen
schwergewicht morgen zu tun also ihr
russischer kollege der fast 20 jahre im
amt ist der andere neulinge auch gerne
schon mal vorgeführt hat auf offener
bühne worauf muss ich bei magda
einstellen
ich bin ganz sicher dass die
außenministerin sich das video genau
angeguckt hat wie vor dem vierten jahr
sergei lavrov den hohen beauftragten der
europäischen union josef
auf offener bühne quasi abgewatscht hat
das war
schlimm
aber man muss natürlich auch sagen es
ist wichtig sergey lavrov auch genau
zuzuhören es gibt auf der welt heute
keinen außenminister weit und breit der
so lange jahre dieses amt innehatte und
der alles alles ganz genau weiß ich habe
großen persönlichen respekt vor den
professionellen qualitäten von sergei
lavrov das ist ein schwieriger kunde
aber es lohnt sich mit ihm ernsthaft zu
reden das hat sich jedenfalls
vorgenommen die botschaft heute in kiew
richtung moskau war ja durchaus schon
klar also eu nato g7 berbalk hat
deutschland klar in diese riege
eingereiht vermutlich mit dem tenor der
westen meint es ernst
reicht das hört moskau diese botschaft
oder braucht es nicht doch schärfere
mitte auch die frage der nordsee
pipeline nord stream 2g auf den tisch
als druckmittel gelegt werden muss das
klassische konzept der nato muss auch
hier angewendet werden nämlich an der
doppelstrategie einerseits
abschreckung möglichst viel möglichst
glaubwürdige umfassende abdeckung und
gekoppelt an ein dialogangebot und bei
der abschreckung habe das ein bisschen
wenn man von vornherein nord stream zwei
sozusagen aus dem spiel nimmt wenn dann
andere stimmen aus deutschland
sanktionen zum thema swift also dem
international zahlen sind aus dem spiel
nehmen dann erscheint die
abschreckungswirkung die wir erzielen
können erst recht gering nachdem wir
schon erklärt haben also
waffenlieferungen kommen für uns
jedenfalls nicht in betrag also ich sehe
hier eine schwachstelle bei unseren
beitrag zu einer umfassenden
abschreckungsstrategie
denn das ist das einzige was das kalkül
putins und der kreml führung tatsächlich
beeinflussen könnte ist der preis eines
militärischen vorgehens möglicherweise
zu hoch dann wird es nicht machen
politikexperte heute abend herzlichen
dank nach berlin
so willkommen zur corona lage die hat in
diesen tagen die besonderheit dass die
instanzen jeden tag auf neue höchstwerte
klettern die grassierende omikron
variante aber als mild eingeschätzt wird
und so plötzlich corona endlich
erscheint irgendwann jedenfalls wohl das
hat den bundesgesundheitsminister dazu
veranlasst heute die klare botschaft
gegen leichtsinn auszugeben und mikron
nicht zu unterschätzen ein appell auch
an die gesundheitsminister der länder
die heute abend unter anderem über die
weitere strategie diskutierten unter
vorsitz von sachsen anhalt aus magdeburg
andreas weise
später nachmittag in magdeburg der
glockenturm des alten rathauses spielt
die ode an die freude
dass alle menschen brüder werden oft nur
ein frommer wunsch in diesen tagen circa
500 haben sich hier versammelt alle
tragen masken sie wollen flagge zeigen
sehen sich als vertreter der großen
mehrheit in der stadt und im land wir
machen alles mit wir lassen hinten wir
halten alle beschränkungen ein und
müssen trotzdem weiter und diese
beschränkung auf uns nehmen weil man
manche leute meinen sie das nicht zu tun
wenn alle mitgemacht hätten von anfang
haben wir immer wahrscheinlich einem
anderen punkt im grunde will eine
minderheit über die mehrheit bestimmen
zur selben zeit gut 200 km weiter
nördlich
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach zu
besuch in schwerin bei
ministerpräsidentin schwesig der grund
klar corona und speziell die omikron
variante bisher sei deutschland ganz gut
mit dieser welle klar gekommen so
lauterbach deutschland ist es gelungen
die verdopplung zeit bei der omicron
variante zu strecken auf mittlerweile
über sechs tage fast sieben tage als in
anderen ländern nicht möglich gewesen da
waren die verdoppelungen zum teil nur 2
drei tage der gesundheitsminister warnt
aber davor omikron nicht ernst zu nehmen
wir haben hat sehr viele ältere menschen
die nicht geimpft sind die aber
gleichzeitig viele risikofaktoren abend
und somit werden wir es in den nächsten
jahr vielleicht sieben bis zehn tagen
werden wir andere verlässliche eine
brauchbare information dazu haben wie
schwer diese welle in deutschland
tatsächlich die also kapazitäten
belasten wird und dann kann man über
möglicherweise notwendige zusätzliche
maßnahmen sprechen jetzt wäre das
verfrüht es kann sein dass solche
massnahmen gar nicht nötig wären dann
schnell zum nächsten termin video
konferenz mit den gesundheitsministerin
und ministern der länder seit gut einer
stunde ist beschlossen die
niedergelassenen ärzte zu unterstützen
indem krankschreibungen per telefon auch
weiterhin möglich sind außerdem wurde
besprochen wie wir wirklich eine
einfache
impfkampagne noch mal machen nicht nur
für den januar sondern auch für den
februar und anders ich dass wir noch
eine einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht
haben wie wir diejenigen noch überzeugen
können sich bis zum 15 15 er hat impfen
zu lassen
am abend dann in magdeburg wieder bilder
die in den letzten wochen demonstranten
ohne maske die polizei löst die
unangemeldete versammlung auf gerangel
festnahmen die polizei hat bis in den
späten abend alle hände voll zu tun
und wir bleiben noch beim thema corona
die detaillierten zahlen jetzt in den
nachrichten die aber mit einer neuen
wichtigen frist beginnt gundula gause
die bundesregierung hat darauf
hingewiesen dass der status als genesene
jetzt nach drei monaten ausläuft die
verkürzung von bisher sechs monaten seit
samstag in kraft sei auf die ansteckende
omikron variante zurückzuführen erklärte
ein sprecher des gesundheitsministeriums
zugleich geht die zahl der in kliniken
aufgenommenen corona patienten zurück
die hospitalisierung rate ist leicht
gesunken auf
3,14 die sieben tage incidents erreicht
währenddessen mit 528 2 einen neuen
höchststand das rkw meldete 34.000 145
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
8890 mehr als vor einer woche 30
todesfälle kamen hinzu
fast fünf jahre nach der anklage ist die
deutsche journalistin michelle tolo in
der türkei freigesprochen worden ihr war
die mitgliedschaft in einer
terrororganisation und terror propaganda
vorgeworfen worden dafür gebe es keine
ausreichenden beweise so das gericht
heute polo war im april 2017 in der
türkei festgenommen worden und saß mehr
als sieben monate zeitweise mit ihrem
kind in untersuchungshaft ehe sie 2018
nach deutschland zurückkehren konnte
justizminister buschmann hat einen
entwurf vorgelegt um den umstrittenen
paragrafen 219 a streichen zu lassen der
so formulieren ist kritiker einem
werbeverbot für schwangerschafts
abbrüche gleichkomme der paragraph sei
rechtlich nicht haltbar so hofmann
frauen würden auch im internet rat
suchen und es könne nicht sein dass
ausgerechnet qualifizierte fachleute
nicht über schwangerschafts abbrüche
sachlich informieren dürften in der
krise um die insolventen im v werften in
mecklenburg vorpommern hat das land vor
gericht einen etappensieg erreicht
zunächst muss ein kredit in höhe von 78
millionen euro nicht gezahlt werden das
landgericht schwerin lehnte den antrag
des werftbesitzer sub der asiatische
konzern genthin hongkong habe keine
existenzielle notlage glaubhaft machen
können der insolvenzverwalter hat
unterdessen mit der auszahlung der
dezember löhne an die rund 2000
mitarbeiter begonnen
nach dem ausbruch eines
unterwasservulkans vor den küsten des
südpazifischen inselreiches tonga ist
das ausmaß der zerstörung weiterhin
unklar sei der gigantischen eruption ist
das archipel größtenteils von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten australien und
neuseeland erkunden die lage aus der
luft und wollen schnellstmöglich mit
hilfslieferungen beginnen eine britin
kam in den fluten es durch den ausbruch
ausgelösten tsunamis ums leben
nach der wahl ist vor der wahl nachdem
in deutschland nun die erste spd
geführte ampel auf bundesebene regiert
stehen in diesem jahr vier
landtagswahlen an es dürfte interessant
sein ob die spd sozusagen mit
kanzlerbonus weitere erfolge einfahren
kann und der cdu im saarland in
schleswig-holstein oder in nordrhein
westfalen ihre macht streitig machen
kann im märz macht das saarland den
anfang wo cdu-ministerpräsident tobias
hans in den umfragen zurück gefallen ist
der wahlkampf dort hat begonnen und das
die karten neu gemischt werden darauf
hoffen
sticken la fontaine land auch die linken
susanne freitag berichtet
mit alten hits in die neue
legislaturperiode die linke an der saar
versucht ihren ewigen streit heute abend
weg zur
spitzenkandidatin barbara spaniol hat
unterstützung von fraktionschef dietmar
bartsch aus berlin die umfragewerte im
keller oskar lafontaine nicht mehr an
bord kein leichter wahlkampfauftakt sind
durch vielfachen streit aufgefallen aber
gerade deshalb ist es eben wichtig die
probleme der menschen aufzunehmen weil
wir deutlich machen müssen dass
interessierte uns und weniger die
internen auseinandersetzungen
orthopädische einlagen aus einem neuen
3d drucker system standen auf dem
terminplan von ministerpräsident tobias
zukunftstechnologien digitalisierung
seine team die cdu leidet unter der
niederlage bei der bundestagswahl
er hat sein amt beerbt muss es sich
jetzt erkämpfen an der groko wieder
festhalten wir sehen dass die anderen
parteien im saarland teilweise
schwierigkeiten haben sich aufzustellen
auch auf eine landtagswahl vorzubereiten
ich glaube dass das schwierig wird mit
solchen partnern zu regieren deswegen
setzen wir auf kontinuität auch in der
großen koalition unter der führung der
cdu in den umfragen aber liegt sie vorne
anke rehlinger
vize-ministerpräsidentin und
wirtschaftsministerin seit acht jahren
auch sie will landeschefin werden
nochmal groko
in welchem zustand sich die cdu befindet
möglicherweise wenn sie auf dem platz 2
1 läuft auch das vermag ich nur schwer
zu beurteilen im bund sieht man sie ist
er die stabilisiert mit fdp landeschef
oliver luksic hatte anke rehlinger in
berlin zusammen die ampel sondiert lief
gar nicht so schlecht sagt sie und
schließt rot gelb nicht aus
eine ampel schwierig die saar-grünen
waren so zerstritten dass sie bei der
letzten bundestagswahl nicht mal eine
liste hatten die neue spitzenkandidatin
lisa becker muss jetzt die parteilager
einen nicht einfachen
die afg will im landtag bleiben zerlegt
sich aber mit einem innerparteilichen
rechtsstreit am freitag erst entscheidet
sich ob sie in allen wahlkreisen eine
gültige liste aufstellen kann der
wahlkampf schwerpunkt steht allerdings
fest dass vordringlichstes thema ist
logischerweise
krone und die absurden und
menschenverachtenden kroner maßnahmen
unserer bundesregierung unsere
landesregierung gestern abend film
festival eröffnung mit den großen
partnern die jetzt wahlkampf
konkurrenten sind traditionell hält hier
der ministerpräsident eine
eröffnungsrede ob es im nächsten jahr
eine ministerpräsidentin sein wird
entscheidet sich im märz
ja genau genommen am 27 schleswig
holstein und nordrhein westfalen folgen
dann im mai und nur noch mal nachrichten
gundela
bundesfinanzminister lindner hat bei
seiner ersten teilnahme an beratungen
der eu amtskollegen auf der einhaltung
der strengen schuldenregel der euro
gruppe bestanden sie seien entscheidend
um die glaubwürdigkeit der staaten
gegenüber den kapitalmärkten zu erhalten
vor allem frankreich fordert dagegen
eine diskussion über eine mögliche
reform der fiskalregeln angesichts
unterschiedlich hoher schulden der euro
länder
zentrales kriterium für die staaten
bleibt dabei die wirtschaftsleistung die
global unter der pandemie leidet china
zweitgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
stemmt sich dagegen mit dem ergebnis
eines robusten wachstums von mehr als 8
prozent im vergangenen jahr frank dabei
hat das riesenreich auch massive
belastungen und krisen ja die das
robuste wachstum erschüttern könnten
längst läuft es auch im reich der mitte
nicht mehr rund erst die stromausfälle
auch in wichtigen industrieregionen dazu
der immense einbruch auf dem für china
so wichtigen immobilienmarkt und nun
droht mit am nikon eine neue gefahr noch
sind es wenige städte die abgeriegelt
worden erwartet wird aber dass sich um
nie kommen auch in der volksrepublik
rasch ausbreiten wird und das ist durch
die strengen restriktionen zu neuen
stillständen den häfen fabriken und im
einzelhandel kommt chinas wirtschaft
droht wie schon zum ende des jahres
weiter an schwung zu verlieren
erneut muss mit gestörten lieferketten
gerechnet werden die deutschland vor
allem bei der einfuhr von halbleitern
oder wichtigen rohstoffen wie silizium
oder magnesium treffen würden doch nicht
nur das deutsche autobauer
erwirtschaften zwischen 30 und 40
prozent ihres umsatzes in china aber
auch so der chefvolkswirt der deutschen
bank stefan schneider für den
maschinenbau und die elektrotechnik ist
china von überragender bedeutung als
absatzmarkt wohlgemerkt und das ist die
andere seite des problems im
bevölkerungsreichsten land der erde
leisten sich viele menschen besonders in
der aufstrebenden mittelschicht gerne
produkte made in germany
dies gilt allerdings nur solange die
wirtschaft weiter kräftig wächst und
nicht die sorgen über hand nehmen frank
bethmann vielen dank
zum zweiten mal in folge ist bayerns in
bayern münchens torjäger robert
lewandowski zum weltfußballer des jahres
gewählt worden der 33 jährige pole
setzte sich bei der abstimmung des
weltverbandes fifa ging lionel messi und
mohammed salat durch und zum welttrainer
gekürt wurde thomas tuchel vom fc
chelsea ein weiterer triumph für den
früheren dortmunder und mainzer nach dem
sieg der champions league in der
deutschen handball nationalmannschaft
sind vor dem abschließenden
vorrundenspiel der europameisterschaft
morgen gegen polen fünf weitere spiele
positiv auf kroner getestet worden nach
torwart andreas wolf sind auch außen
casting hier links und rückraumspieler
kai häfner betroffen mit lukas mertens
und luca witzke fallen nun sieben
spieler corona bedingt aus das zdf
überträgt die partie morgen ab 17 uhr 45
nach dem tennis star novak djokovic
australien verlassen musste kann sich
nun olympiasieger alexander zverev bei
den australian open hoffnungen auf
seinen ersten grand slam titel machen
der auftakt für die titel-mission gelang
obwohl es wäre beim ersten runden match
gegen daniel altmaier aus kempen nicht
ganz in form war in drei sätzen gewann
der hamburger das deutsche duelle
kino kann verführen die grenzen zwischen
realität und illusion verwischen und
kann entführen den welten in denen alles
möglich scheint ein solches kino kaliber
startet diese woche und darum kommt man
gar nicht herum denn nightmare allee so
der titel des films wird schon jetzt als
oscar kandidat gehandelt das spiel mit
der fantasie ein skrupelloser schwindler
der hoch hinaus will und dann tief fällt
diese geschichte führt in die 40er jahre
zurück und ist doch auch heute aktuell
findet nation
amerika ende der 30er jahre
[Musik]
zu der bunten truppe eines wandernden
jarmatz stößt ein neues gesicht der
charmante aber zwielichtige stanton karl
eingespielt von bradley cooper schnell
erobert er sich einen festen platz in
der faszinierenden und bizarren welt vor
allem die kunst der manipulation
interessiert ihn bei einem erfahrenen
hellseher paar schaut er sich tricks ab
[Musik]
wie der gedankenleser werden soll es mir
bitte konzentrieren sie sich auf das
objekt in meiner hand professor der alte
pete führt ihm vor wie er so tut als
könne er mit toten sprechen oder
geheimnisse und rätseln was können sie
mir verraten
armatur rede arbeit
nicht gold aber es war nicht deine
ursprünglich nicht wahr du hast sie
eingesteckt
gestohlen ist es nicht so
was ist wahr was ist falsch was ist eine
lüge was die wahrheit darum geht es und
das sind wichtige fragen gerade
heutzutage wo wir sehen wie uns leute
ständig alternative fakten als realität
verkaufen wollen zum beispiel manche
politiker oder populisten und das ist
erschreckend und verunsichert und flößt
mir angst ein
[Applaus]
noch eine gravur der ehrgeizige stent
steigt auf zum erfolgreichen hellseher
der feinen gesellschaft bis er die
mysteriöse lilith trifft ich werde jetzt
die frage stellen
was befindet sich in der tasche
fasziniert besucht denn ihre elegante
praxis für psychoanalyse will sich mit
ihr zusammen tun denn auch sie kennt
profitable geheimnisse ihrer kundschaft
was für amerika oder nightmare elli ist
ein opulentes meisterwerk ein film nach
im stil der alten hollywood klassiker
mit cate blanchett und bradley cooper s
geniale gegenspieler sie sind nicht gut
und ich weiß das
ich konnte auch nicht
ich wollte eine moderne version dieser
filme drehen von denen alle beklagen sie
würden heute nicht mehr gemacht und ich
wollte eine amerikanische tragödie
erzählen über menschen die schreckliche
entscheidungen treffen weil sie besessen
sind von gier von erfolg und von macht
werden ausgesägt
zu ihrem modell toro ist ein poetischer
bild starker film gelungen düster
grandios und mitreißend über die
abgründe der seele und das gefährliche
spiel mit der lüge
das ist ja wohl eine empfehlung ab
donnerstag im kino und jetzt gibt's
schon montagskino mit einer
bestsellerverfilmung der schneemann und
um 05 direkt danach meldet sich
christopher wehrmann mit unserem
heute-journal update so ist es bis
morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die zehn wärmsten
jahre sind nach 2010 aufgetreten und
sind hier aufgereiht und
2021 fällt auf den sechsten platz und
das wärmste jahr war 2016 bisher so
ähnlich wie das jahr 2020 ganz an der
spitze aber die meiste wärme wird von
den ozeanen und von den weltmeeren
aufgenommen und da zeichnet sich ein
neuer rekord für 2021 ab es ist das
wärmste jahr bisher in den weltmeeren
schauen aufs wetter und da bekommen wir
kaltluft aus dem norden die sich weiter
nach südosten verlagert das hoch dehnt
sich aus und danach wird es kurzfristig
trockener aber noch haben wir es mit
regen und schnee zu tun schnee in den
mittelgebirgen das ganze verlagert sich
nach südosten im osten deutschlands
klart es auf und es wird dort am
kältesten sein mit temperaturen bis
minus 3 grad und sechs grad plus ganz im
westen deutschlands morgen dann in der
norddeutschen tiefebene viele wolken mit
etwas regen ansonsten auch mal
sonnenschein zum beispiel im osten mit
den meisten sonnenschein gibt es an den
alpen und im südwesten dort wird es
allerdings am kühlsten bleiben morgen
mit temperaturen von zwei grad so
ähnlich wie im vogtland am mildesten im
rheinland bei acht grad die nächsten
tage am mittwoch gibt es im nordwesten
regen im süden aber auch mal
sonnenschein bei ein bis sieben grad
dann geht der regen am donnerstag fast
überall in schnee über nur im westen
deutschlands kann es dann regnen das bei
kräftigen wind aus nord damit ein
schöner art